what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time or
while she's trying to get rich wrestlers
she's trying to get her lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
palina eva liva marinova pompliano she
hates when i say that so that's why i
say it every day
p-i-m-p don't forget that lunch money is
now sponsored by block
five block five dot com
slash pomp go sign up for an account you
can earn up to 8.6
apy in that interest bearing account
they have all sorts of financial
products for crypto investors
including they are coming out with a
bitcoin rewards credit card where it's a
regular credit card you
swipe it and you'll get paid back in
bitcoin rather than cashback airline
miles
blackfine.com what up
what up new york attorney general warns
cryptocurrency
industry play by the rules or we will
shut you down
she said uh there are many dangers of
the digital assets
we are sending a clear message to the
entire industry that you either play by
the
so what does playing by the rules mean
here's the deal new york attorney
general is discriminating
that's what's happening here just so
we're very very clear the new york
attorney in general
is discriminating and against an entire
industry
in an attempt then she's just saying
play by the rules
crypto companies are more regulated than
the financial banks you want to play by
the rules
how about you go shut down jp morgan go
shut down citibank go shut down wells
fargo go shut down the criminal
enterprises that have laundered
trillions of dollars
through their banks and turned a blind
eye go shut down goldman sachs go shut
down the banks that where the real crime
happens where the real money laundering
happens
the the companies that have actually
been charged with crimes
go shut them down why don't they have to
play by the rules why are you trying to
protect the incumbents
at the loss of innovation that's the
problem is the
the government and the regulatory bodies
are protecting the status quo
to be fair when there is an emerging
asset class there is a lot of greed
and uh uh you know malicious players in
the mix
the legacy banks laundered more money
than the entire size of the crypto
industry
there's not this all garbage it's all
narrative it's
all nonsense if you want to be serious
then go ahead and make them play by the
rules make the banks play by the same
rules as everybody else
stop allowing them to launder money to
work with criminals
and to allow them to do all the things
that we know are against the rules
why are they allowed to do that so
instead of
targeting a very small industry in which
it's obviously
that you're it's obvious that you're
discriminating against them
you're discriminating against that
industry you're preventing
innovation in an attempt to protect the
incumbents in the status quo
make everyone play by the same rules we
love playing by the rules
but if i have to pay taxes when i spend
my currency
then why don't they have to pay a tax
when they spend their currency
if i have to get a special license to
run a crypto company in new york state
called a bit license why don't they have
to get a special license to run their
business
crypto companies are over regulated
compared to legacy players
and legacy players break the law much
more
than the crypto company speaking of the
incumbent goldman sachs
restarted its cryptocurrency trading
desk and will begin
dealing bitcoin futures and
non-deliverable forwards for clients
from next week from next week uh the
bank is also exploring the potential for
a bitcoin exchange traded fund
wow so okay so that's interesting
by the way we shouldn't shut down jp
morgan city
goldman sachs wells fargo or any of
these guys they're doing the best that
they can
sure maybe there's some malicious actors
internally but as you can tell
they also agree that this technology is
innovative they agree that this asset
class is somewhere that investors should
place
so i'm curious is goldman sachs hiring
from the crypto world or is these like
legacy people who are trying to work on
these things
it's both they bring some people from
the crypto industry in and they also
they have
some people internally that end up being
interested in it
anything else to say about goldman no
what i have nothing else to say
cboe kicks off bitcoin etf
clock with van eck filing
the chicago board options exchange has
officially filed to list shares of
vaynex
bitcoin exchange traded fund wow
well this is innovative um didn't didn't
i meet the team
of vanic uh you've met gabor yeah yeah
they're very smart
um there's an etf in canada there's
multiple ones now oh this is in canada
no there's an etf that's been approved
and is now trading in canada
there's etps etns exchange traded notes
exchange shaded products
all throughout europe there is no etf in
the united states
the united states is last that's what's
happened here
the united states has last have we lost
our minds
are we going to be the leader on a
global stage in
finance are we going to allow american
investors
to have exposure in the same types of
products that they can do
in canada and in europe or are we going
to be the lagger
are we going to say no you know what
we're not going to participate we're
going to prevent
them from getting that participation or
that exposure knock off the nonsense
approve the etf and let's roll
there's some very very innovative and
forward-thinking people at both the sec
the cftc uh fincen all the way on down
right
i've talked to many of these people they
are working their butts off trying to
get this thing through
there's still tons of concerns and
issues that they're trying to address
it's gonna get done let's get it done
quickly and so why is an etf
important there's a lot of asset
managers that that's how they want to
get exposure
there's also a lot of people that uh
whether it's through their retirement
accounts or other types of things they
don't want to go sign up and get a
crypto
account or crypto specific account they
want to do it through their normal
brokerage account and so etf basically
opens up accessibility
and it leads to pretty massive capital
inflows historically
cool rocket lab is going
public via a spac merger and it's also
building
a larger launch vehicle called neutron
to support
heavier payloads so they're basically
they're going public
to get access to funds to build this
large rocket i actually don't know that
much about rocket lab but it sounds
awesome what what is their main uh
product right now
because they're talking about creating
this neutron which is like a heavy
payload thing but what do they do
so elec so electron
is their current smaller launch vehicle
uh and they also have a space systems
division that
supplies components into a number of
spacecraft including some of the mega
constellations
i love space i wish i could go up there
and hang out for a day
with the robots on mars
i don't want to go hang out with robots
well there's only robots would you go on
a date with me to space
would i come back maybe that's part of
the adventure
i don't know about all that it's like
when you go to a broadway play
is it going to be good maybe maybe not i
think comparing a broadway play to go
into space and not knowing if you come
back have you seen me at a broadway play
i am
lost in the sauce i don't know where i
am or what is going on
one time we went to cirque du soleil in
vegas and a clown
invited him up on stage a literal clown
to dance dance
and he danced and have a video of it
i was sitting in the front row and he
came and he got me and i got up on stage
i gave him a little dance
so the clown came up to me and i thought
he was gonna invite me so i was like
getting ready to go up and he was like
excuse me can i get him and i was like
hey you he spun him around
i spun the clown around ain't nobody
spitting me around i spun the clown
around
i don't know the video says otherwise
clown had big ass shoes and a
small ass brain okay um
okay so elizabeth the warren and bernie
sanders are proposing a three percent
wealth tax on billionaires uh they
proposed a two percent annual tax on
wealth over 50 million
rising to 3 percent for wealth over 1
billion
obviously there's pros and cons to
something like this
about 100 000 americans or fewer than 1
000 families would be subject to a
wealth tax in 2023
uh the policy would raise at least 3
trillion over a decade
but then hold on a second but then i
read that
the legislation would invest 100 billion
dollars into
irs systems and personnel to ensure a 30
audit rate for the super wealthy and
impose a 40
exit tax on wealthy americans who seek
to renounce their citizenship
to avoid a wealth tax i don't know
i don't know i feel like what's the
point of this so you're gonna shovel
money into the irs so
they can tax people i don't know it's
just a whole thing
but oh wait okay go on these people are
stupid
they're stupid they're literally stupid
they're socialists
who try to come in and say tax the rich
tax the rich hey elizabeth warren why
don't you just donate all your money
many of these billionaires have pledged
to donate 90 plus percent of their
wealth
edge yeah why don't you donate you're a
millionaire why don't you donate money
where have you donated your money oh
okay why did you cut it off at 50
million what are you worth
40 million why don't you subject
yourself to the 3
tax here's the problem is they're idiots
literally bad leadership leads to bad
outcomes and what we are watching is a
bunch of socialists that's what these
people are
they want to take things from someone
group and
redistribute the wealth to somebody else
and what they are going to do is they're
going to continue to do this and they're
not going to stop
but the 100 billion dollars that they're
gonna put in the irs and the three
trillion dollars over a decade why do
you need my money you can just create it
you just created three trillion dollars
last year
out of thin air you just are about to
create another 1.9 trillion dollars out
of thin air
the problem in an income problem it's
not a problem of can they get more money
into the system the problem is that you
can't stop spending
that's the problem so elizabeth warren
you're dumb
stop this is not how you solve the
problem it's not to disincentivize
capitalism you know what the actual
solution to the problem is
why don't you stop devaluing the
currency so that the people at the
bottom
of the wealth inequality gap don't feel
like they continue to fall further and
further behind
because what happens for those that
don't understand is that as you
print more money as you create more
money in the system the rich get richer
literally they hold investable assets
they don't hold dollars and therefore
the asset price continues to increase
over time
and they get wealthier at the same time
the bottom 45
of americans are losing their wealth
they're watching it get degradated away
and devalued away
and so elizabeth warren is one of the
greatest perpetrators
of wealth inequality in our country
along with many of her peers
she built a 12 million fortune and
apparently she and her husband hold
much of their wealth in retirement
accounts i would so
just so we're clear elizabeth warren has
an
eight-figure an eight-figure
net worth in 2019 and a lot of it
invested in the stock market and since
the stock markets have
uh gone up so much she's probably worth
15 to 20 million dollars
and she's doing it in tax shelter
entities she is taking money
and putting it into entities so she
doesn't have to pay taxes to the
government
somebody please explain to me how we got
to a situation
where oh we should take money from those
rich people
but not from me the rich person
elizabeth warren yeah it's interesting
how it's often separated with like
business people and politicians plenty
of politicians are very rich
these people are absolutely morons
so so she proposed this ultra wealthy
tax she's banging the drum
but she's facing an uphill battle
because
guess who our gal our friend
janet yellen is up in arms saying that
that would be too messy to
enact i think she said uh she said
um she said a wealth tax would be too
messy to implement and then
warren said then janet and i need to
have a conversation about implementation
so elizabeth warren while americans
around the country suffered and they had
their businesses shut down
and they were prevented from making a
living and they had to become dependent
on the government
elizabeth warren kept taking her
paycheck elizabeth warren
if you were a real leader you would have
said i'm worth
10 plus million dollars i don't need my
salary
i'll take my salary and i'll give it to
a small business owner i'll help
people not the profile profile i don't
need money either profiles killing it
but i'll help other people i didn't see
one single politician during the
coronavirus
during the pandemic during the absolute
insane lockdowns
not one politician said i will forego
my salary as long as you as a business
owner have to forego yours
that's what real leadership would look
like but these insane
wealthy elite socialists
want to take all your money and give it
to everybody else but they don't want to
give up any of theirs
they want to hide their money in tax
shelter i'm always skeptical of people
who want to spend other people's money
but don't want to give away their own
fools okay that's what they are they're
all fools all right
it's ask lunch bunny time hashtag ask
lm in the comments we're gonna save
moist for last today
uh stu stu asks why is there a 20-minute
timer in the corner
because we can't tell time stew we can't
tell
time because if there wasn't a timer i
think we would just go on
and on and on kind of like no we used to
do this and we used to be able to see
the timer and we said we're going to do
20 minutes or less you know and now we
recorded a different way
so we can't see the 20 minutes we got
rid of the timer no
keeping the timer and the fact that stu
asked me to stay in forever
i think it's redundant thank you steve
your head is redundant
my head is perfectly shiny
what a year 2020 was asks hi
as we approach the one year anniversary
of lunch money is it on march 31st when
it was just
anthony alone or is it on april 1st when
i
joined what present will you be giving
to each other on this significant day
yeah anthony what present are you going
to give me
on april 1st when i came and saved
the day if you guys watch lunch money
number one
thank god i joined on april 1st for
lunch money number two and i stayed ever
since tell them the real story why you
joined on april 1st because it was april
fool's day and i need to find a fool to
join me on the show
i was waiting for this joke i already
knew it was coming that's old that's old
um so yeah i'm not getting you any gifts
i don't do gifts i do experiences
i gave you this big cup as a gift
thank you it's a big gift
i will be letting you guys know what he
gets me on april 1st
i'm gonna get you a clown suit it's
moist time
moist what up moist counter okay uh
day 13 of commenting on every episode
until palm gives me a call i'm not
surprised youtube is censoring me
they aren't a fan of truth speakers the
first thing i do in the morning is put
my contacts into action
so i can actually see objects instead of
blurs my naked eye
my naked c with 2060 vision according to
my most recent optimum
optometrist optometrist appointment
optometrist i think it is
up tom okay whatever i then brush my
teeth and use the restroom
showering is only part of my morning
routine if i have something important
that day
otherwise i just shower post workout wow
okay well now re
read the rest of the thing hashtag moist
gang hashtag unlease the moisture
unleash unleash the moisture all right
listen contacts oh god i got 20 20. you
know i'm just got that 20 20 vision
actually i think i got 2015 which means
i got like super eyes that's so dumb
no i really do think that's what the
optometrist said to me
little go in there they'll put the
things on there like read the letter
when is the last time you've been to
an optometrist when you were four no i
had to go do it when i went to the army
they were like can you see and then they
were like damn
this guy's got like hawk vision but for
real i got 20 i guess 2015 is uh is the
vision
lord have mercy on myself i'm gonna go
the optometrist i'm gonna bring back the
results i'll be like damn he got hawk
vision
my foreign don't worry all right so
moist here's my question of the day
if given the choice between
seeing these three movies which would
you choose by the way he was wrong you
guys were right full metal jacket for
the win
not ice cream they say it in jar head i
think
the lion king
rugrats the movie the hell
titanic titanic
you gotta choose one choose your player
carefully
which movie are you watching carefully
by the way
i just want to let everyone know i don't
care about politics i'm
independent but by the way if you're a
fool and you're a politician
i will let you know all right great
seeing you guys today see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block life's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends